écouteurs j'ai besoin pour un résultat
sombre de quelqu'un qui travaille à mon
côté dans l'ombre et qui m'aident à
bâtir un grand événement je ne suis pas
méchant mais il est tellement longue le
plus délicat qui t'ont tout vergogne
doit retrousser ses manches et faire la
besogne
tu seras riche mais il faut m'aider
sandri a dressé comme le font les
oiseaux leur la nuit un bon fils est
caché sous un miroir qui brille un piège
des alouettes ou bien de jeunes filles
il faut par quelques plans terrible et
merveilleux tu n'es pas que je pense un
homme scrupuleux mais venger
ranger
oui de qui d'une femme ne me dit pas
plus halte-là sur mon âme mon coussin en
ceci pas là mon sentiment
celui qui bassement est tortueuse mans
se venge ayant le droit de porter une
lame noble par une intrigue sommes sur
une femme et qui n'est gentilhomme
agitons alguazil plus futiles camp de
castille futile est suivi de son clairon
sonne en tête à tamar peut-il thouars
nash est d'ores et de chamarré marquis
et vicomte et fils des anciens pour eux
n'est pour moi qu'un marc aux sinistrés
ténébreux que je voudrais pour prix de
sa lâcheté ville voire pendra 4 cloud
ogives et de la ville césar ajouté pas
un mot cet outrage en garde est votre
secret et gardez votre argent
je comprends qu'on tue et convoler
compris que par une nuit noire on force
le pastis d'assaut la hache au point
avec sans fil bustier qu'on égorge esta
fier geôliers et qui est douce
saillantes et hurlant bandits que nous
sommes un oeil pour oeil dent pour dent
c'est bien homme contre homme mais
doucement détruire une femme est creusé
ce qu'il ne trappe et contre elle abuse
et qui sait de son humeur peut-être au
hasard deux prendre ce pauvre oiseau
dans quelques clous vis deux jours plus
tôt qui arrivait jusqu'à ce déshonneur
plutôt qu'être à ce prix affichés au
seigneur et je le dise ici pour dieu qui
voit mon âme
j'aimerais mieux plutôt qu'être à ce
point infâme ville odieux pervers
misérable et flétrie qu'un chien ronge
amokrane au pied du pilori cousins vont
bien fait je n'aurais nulle envie tant
que je trouverai vivent ma libre vis aux
fontaines de l'eau dans les champs le
grand air à la ville un voleur qui ma
vie de l'hiver dans mon âme l'oubli dé
prospérité mortes et devant vos palais
monsieur de larges portes aux jeux puis
à midi sans souci du réveil dormir la
tête à l'ombre les pieds au soleil
radieux dans de nous de dieu sait
qu'elle est logist avec les gens le
cours vos pareils don salluste je vous
laisse et je reste avec mes chenapans je
vis avec les loups non avec les serpents
à l'installer m abrégeant la visite
c'est pour m'envoyer en prison fait vite
un nom je vous croyais c'est un peu
endurci l'épreuve vous est bonne et vous
a réussi je suis content de vous votre
main je vous prie
comment je n'ai parlé que par
plaisanterie tout ce que j'ai dis là
c'est pour vous éprouvez rien de plus ça
veut bout vous me fait rêver
la femme le complot cette vengeance ou
leur imagination chimère à la bonne
heure et l'offre de payer mes dettes
vision et les 500 du cac imagination
je vais vous les cherchez visage de
traître dans la bouche dit oui le regard
dit peut-être
[Musique]